well if you were looking forward to
Final Fantasy 15 next month I've got
some bad news the game has been delayed
on the plus side it's not for that much
longer Final Fantasy 15 will now release
on November 29th square enix released a
statement explaining that the delay
allows the team to quote further polish
and conduct quality testing the studio
also put out a video featuring game
director Hajime Tabata who personally
apologized for the delay saying from the
moment we joined this project our vision
was to create a level of freedom and
realism previously unseen in the series
regrettably we need a little bit more
time to deliver on this vision and are
confident that this new release date
will help us achieve this as the
director and lead of this project I wish
to personally apologize for the
additional weight Final Fantasy 15 s
delay will also prevent the need for a
day one patch that update will now be on
the disk already implemented in the game
adding that content to the master
version is what caused the delay you can
certainly look forward to plenty of
GameSpot coverage when FF 15 does come
out but to keep up to date with all the
biggest news from Square Enix in the
meantime you're already in the right
place